quand son tour de lancer la balle est
arrivée
ce petit garçon a préféré se laisser
porter par la musique ambiante
une chorégraphie improvisée qui cumule
déjà des dizaines de milliers de vues il
a fallu couper le son pour regagner son
attention
mine de rien il frappe la balle et
revient dans le match on lui souhaite de
marquer autant pour que sur le
dancefloor l'environnement même s'ils ne
jouent pas moins que la gêne sur
l'intelligence l'environnement qu'on va
poser chez cet enfant le fait qu'il soit
épanouie avec des amis des sorties de la
culture des plants de choses ça peut
être un enfant qui est extrêmement
heureux bien sûr bien si on va on dit
rb6 l'heureux et je crois que quand même
si elle est terrible a gâché par la
théorie c'est que plus on est con plus
on est heureux voilà qu'est ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise le corps
j'ai une vraie connexion avec les allées
moore voilà j'ai un chien j'achète où
est logée en pleine jungle et tout et
tout cubain j'entends plein de bruits de
soi surtout et j'essaie de limiter ses
marrons parce qu'ils répètent chaque
fois que je dis alors je suis en
communication hamed pas faussé
c'est plus facile de comprendre déjà les
mots que les humains ma chienne voit
votre petite chienne ou la wii
chaîne c'est ma femme pratiquement à la
remplacer toutes les femmes du monde
c'est un rêve absolu lma débarrasser du
sexe l'adorent pour ça vous a débarrassé
du sexe a depuis que j'ai fait quinze
ans j'ai totalement oublié ce truc là
qui d'ailleurs ce bon c'est très
surévalué le sait
ça s'arrête et c'est fini net et du
mythe voleurs voilà le concept de
l'émission en gros au nord de la suède
un troupeau d'élan traversent chaque
année le fleuve banger manal veulent
immigrer toujours au début du printemps
pour aller sur un pâturage qui est de
l'autre côté du fleuve et cette épopée
est très très lente parce qu'il ne se
jette pas tous va bien ou dans l'eau ils
vont petit à petit par petits groupes ou
à lorient et qu'ils vont tout seul
certains ventes aux parcs avec leurs
enfants lui ayant mai c'est poisson
rouge se taïwanais touche à tout
créateur et youtuber est l'artisan de
cette poussette aquarium car dit-il si
lui même était un poisson il serait
heureux d'explorer d'autres horizons sa
dernière invention en tout cas estimé à
280 euros fait déjà le tour du monde sur
les réseaux sociaux des producteurs
suédois 70 il ya quatre ans on va faire
une émission de cette migration des
élans et ils ont installé des dizaines
de caméras le long du fleuve alors voilà
ils ont installé des caméras infrarouges
pour filmer la nuit ils ont aussi
investi dans des drones et cette année
pour une quatrième saison ils ont
diffusé des images pendant trois
semaines plusieurs heures par jour sur
une chaîne de la télévision suédoise et
24 heures sur 24 sur un site internet et
c'est un succès fou oui c'est un grand
succès son regret sans aucune embellie
ex valley j'ai eu une chance folle j'ai
eu des femmes magnifiques et mis toute
ma vie puisque je sais pas ce que c'est
que des méduses aisée mais toujours les
femmes plus j'ai aimé plus ses aventures
plus les coups de chaud qu'est ce que
voulaient les mecs de mon accent l'aic
le groin en avant et que vous faites ce
soir j'ai honte non mais vraiment en
plus les vieux qui baissent ça me
dégoûte non mais c'est vrai vraiment ça
me dégoûte
bruno comme vous êtes un bon brand
heures je veux donner
je veux donner
des places pour aller à la foire du
trône rien [ __ ] encore plus les
adeptes de ces activités doivent réussir
à repasser tout en pratiquant un sport
ou une activité risquée un risque et au
fond de l'eau avec des bouteilles en
faisant du roller du ski ou encore de la
varappe quel intérêt ou quand ça fait
des questions c'est voilà normal ou
chelou de lancer une chenille un mariage
bonne idée lancée les attentions normal
ou chez nous c'est quoi une chenille
normal
c'est une chance que j'ai c'est cheyrou
direct quel poisson est la vedette du
clip baby show
[Musique]
ouais j'avais un poisson dessin animé
mais salopette face et nemo et c'est là
où on se rend compte que parmi toutes
ces qualités eric est complètement
bilingue
votre site vous avez fini la compétition
parce que c'est la suite aux virées
notre dossier du jour consacré
l'apéritif une tradition bien ancrée en
france place
l'instar de la paire ou de vente ou pas
de cerises et les pistaches c'est le
souci
savez vous qui la réponse dans minute de
rendez vous demain 17h les habits pour
le domaine partie de cela avec notre
championne sidnei bonne soirée à tous on
vous aime gros bisous et vive les
portables à dos noir